[Music]
come on
foreign
[Music]
come on
let us be honest as Africans Ghana does
not want cocaine so they are very strict
loss on cocaine we've stopped it once
you see cocaine somebody gets arrested
Ghana doesn't want armed robbery once we
see I'm robbery there is something
serious about it as a country we pretend
we do not want E-Waste but we do not
have laws to stop the second hand Goose
from coming to this country it is sheer
pretense it is sheer hypocrisy the
things we do not want as a country we
fight it
and that is our culture that's it's
about business about money I mean it's
it's the second hand Market in Ghana is
very huge there's a country where we
don't produce much most of the things we
do is import trade import trade import
Street now
as a developing country people are
beginning to get interested and you know
gadgets
an unemployed country they don't have
money to buy brand new gadgets so there
is a huge market for second-hand Goods
[Music]
oh yeah
a lot
a day after repair all you want and at
some days come I feel about like three
or five we know what we are buying if we
want to buy we do know buy which one
we buy one the one we can repel on it
yes I like it too because I want to have
no more knowledge more than the one I
have here so I like the way
[Music]
up to date
yeah
we buy home use electronics and we raise
we repair some we sell some sometimes we
buy them untested that is the rule of
the game
sometimes we buy it untested some people
to test it before you buy so the
untested ones when we bring them
sometimes
we are able to
fix them back there are other ones too
they cannot be fixed but mostly
uh when you buy about 100 you can about
80 percent can be repairable
I think as a country
it is not a priority we've not been
serious about it although we know it
exists and we know it is dangerous there
is no concepted effort as a country in
addressing this issue our position has
been cleared the law is clear anybody
who deposits illegal waste you send it
back if you don't and we take it away
recycle it in Ghana you pay for the cost
proposal to take from the last verse of
the Cartoon Planet song
we the planets here you can be one too
seven of the planet is the thing to do
losing and polluted is not the way hear
what Captain Planet has to say the power
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
it is we ghanaians if we know this is
bad and our leadership knows this is bad
what have they done over the decades so
we may sign conventions and and speak
about it it's nice to put on suits and
go and stand on TV you know it was as
bad is affecting ghanaians deep down in
their hearts
in their daily activities what are they
doing to stop it
nothing the leadership of this country
has over these years closed one eye on
that illegality because stopping it will
cost them some votes and to take a woman
means working together
to resolve this challenge
if our president goes to sign something
tomorrow as I signed already on E-Waste
if it is just a convention that was
signed in Geneva or UK or Thailand or
Europe somewhere my grandmother doesn't
know about it she's not going to school
before
they are in their majority
there are almost over 25 different
terminals you have to cover the 25
terminals but miss with the
misdescription of goods you cannot even
cover
25 percent you cannot if you have to
shred a container it takes you almost a
whole day to share the 45 star container
and whilst you are in there doing that
other areas are free to do what they
want now the things that are coming from
EU and you realize that the Customs the
Border controls the police they all see
it and they leave it and it comes here
it takes me almost about 12 000 US
dollars to re-export a container from
here
that is my country's money that's the
truth every electronic Gadget you buy
there's a disposal fee attached to it
who takes that money
when they impose these things and their
things get to the Ghana ports okay the
authorities of this country they charge
some tax on those goods if you know
these goods are bad why are you charging
tax on it
the the countries that did the best they
had no natural resources no diamonds no
oil what did they have fixers they had
people in Singapore that were buying
used hard drives from the U.S and and
repairing them until they were so good
at it that Western Digital and Seagate
they built factories there and that's
what we want to see 10 years from now
[Music]
a TV repairman is like being an engineer
you know that's like
they don't have the choice to go to MIT
you know to become a rocket engineer
there they've learned to do something
themselves by studying the textbooks
and with their own hands they fixed the
wires fix the circuit boards and make
something that somebody in Africa can
now afford now they can watch the World
Cup before they couldn't
now they can get online and get a Gmail
account before they couldn't
and you know what in the end
the manufacturers are going to be happy
because the more people in Africa that
can afford to get on the internet the
more people in Africa and South America
and and India that kind of that can
learn to have a Facebook account it's
someday those people are going to want a
new computer
[Music]
the government doesn't have the the
audacity the Courage the tenacity to
stop some of these things because it is
you see once you stop it say it affects
several thousands of people
you're going to create a huge
unemployment situation
if you go to abubishi there are several
families who who who hook only put bread
on their table through some of these
things they burn them looking for copper
innate or one aluminum or one metal or
the other any government that they says
we are stopping all these things that
they go is afraid to lose votes as
afraid to lose that constituency of
Voters that was the issue
thank you
[Music]
foreign
so now here we see we never get money to
go get another house yes
do we have a lack of job opportunity it
is our work we can't stop it some even
sent to hospital because of the cancer
because of the god cancer on it so they
can't stop it because of the work all
right you know when they stop it they
can't get money to eat they can't even
give money to save their life for me for
instance
I have to do a work which is what I can
do but sometimes we force ourselves to
do things we cannot which we cannot do
but we force ourselves to do it because
of our lack of money or lack of job
that's why we are doing these things you
know some even kind some you can even
work here till they die here because but
they want to get more they didn't get it
at the same time they die
thank you
okay
well these are very young people who
also work here at the dump site
collecting the e-list because they are
not so strong what they do is to sit the
soil and they would find some metals
they also go to sell and then have some
money to buy some food and then it is
way there once they weigh their stuff
then they paid some money another person
comes to buy the west and it is taken to
the pot so it is taken to uh some
companies that would need copper or
would need other metals
[Music]
thank you
Venice
well this is more or less the hospital
for them so if they come here they'll
complain or I have stomach I vomit I run
then you give them medicine most of them
when they come you give them the
medicine they'll tell you they can't
afford it so you have to give them the
one that is
and that is not positive
[Music]
we found severe contamination of the
environment around where the waste is
being carried out with a whole range of
chemicals and it's similar to what we've
found at E-Waste recycling sites in some
other countries as well so we found
extremely high levels of some toxic
Metals things like lead and cadmium and
also a whole complex mixture of organic
chemicals now many of these are put in
their devices when they're manufactured
some of them are generated when the
Plastics in electronics are burnt a lot
of the chemicals are highly persistent
they just don't break down or break down
very slowly in the environment so
they'll stay there for many years to
come and some of them can even build up
in the food chain so this whole mixture
of chemicals is causing severe
environmental contamination around where
these E-Waste are being recycled
[Music]
thank you
somebody discovers a new problem a new
environmental problem you have to have a
solution to it and that's what the
parcel convention was for me it was
basically the international community's
response to the phenomenon of waste
dumping from developed countries in
developing countries where they're not
where there are no controls people
didn't even know what it was people
didn't know the danger and you had this
problem you had massive amounts of
really hazardous dangerous waste being
shipped from Europe and the United
States and other developed countries to
Africa to Eastern Europe and just dump
there and people were you know killed or
some people died people got diseases you
know there was massive pollution
animals died you know rivers and
wetlands and whatever were polluted so
for me it was really at the time a
solution to to to make people aware of
this that this is really a problem that
it had to be stopped
[Music]
foreign
and I'm one of the co-founders of the
restart project which we started in
London in June 2012 and we've been
running now for over two years for over
70 events just in London alone and
approximately close to 50 events outside
of London and internationally still in
the past two years the restart project
is a social Enterprise which we created
in London with the objective of changing
people's relationship with technology
learning how to repair things and by
doing that learning more how to have
control over the digital devices that
are multiplying in our everyday life
well the restart project was set up with
a very simple slogan that I think is
valid for people everywhere in the world
and that slogan is do not despair just
repair I think sometimes we
we underestimate the powerful reality of
taking something apart learning how it
works learning what the fault was and
being personally empowered together with
other individuals that help you to put
it back together plug it and see it
working again and in a sense our
attachment to that device becomes much
stronger afterwards and a lot of people
end up struggling with things that they
used to love and that they associate
personal memories too and they can't
find a way to fix them so they just put
them in a corner of their house and move
on but it is so inspiring to see people
learn a new skill and learn how instead
and wasting stuff they can give it a new
life
[Music]
foreign
the problem is not telling us this thing
is dangerous every Ghanaian knows that
once you are burning these things and
I'm consuming them it is dangerous to my
health you don't need to go to school to
know that ah those films I am inhaling
is dangerous to my health immediately it
makes you start coughing it talks you
you can see it you don't need to be a
doctor we know it is bad
that we know
uh
you see we are suffering actually uh
government ought to come out to do
something to read to for we the youth to
to at least uh establish some good
business or
factories social investment so that uh
when we get a foreign investors to come
in they can also build something better
or factories for this our young youth
Brothers to also benefit from that
cables that we Bend here yes you see
very well
[Music]
thank you
what we did was took three of the
leaders the The Three Musketeers
[Music]
and said hey you guys take four or five
of these piles of wires that you were
going to burn today put them in a sack
and bring them up to tamale with us next
week because we're going to do an
experiment we're going to show you
something
because it turns out that one of the
laptop technicians is from the same
Village as them and his dad's a
metalsmith
sule is camel Dean's dad and sule had
these ideas when we said hey we need to
do something constructive he said Hey
what if uh we we cut the wire in a way
that it doesn't burn it and my dad can
hire some people to help him make it
into jewelry and we can tell people hey
when you buy this
instead of donating money or having your
taxes go to a million dollar shredding
machine that you can have a direct
impact and I don't know if it's going to
work
but it's cool to see you know
uh an African technician bring his idea
to the table
in the north they don't have like ways
and meals to be able to cater for
themselves you know most of them you see
here they don't have parents some have
single parents some don't at all so due
to this they were brought here to be
able to work and send some money home
and also feed themselves but when they
come here they found out that here it's
not like what they they have been told
or they have been the people told them
to to to to be so now
they they are here and they are sleeping
over here on this damn site what we call
the E-Waste so they sleep here always
both afternoon morning and evening
they they eat over here they do
everything over here by burning this
crap so when they Bend this crap they
end something small like one Ghana CD
two Ghana cedi up to let's say five
Ghana cedi those who want to become
mechanics those who want to become they
want to become seamstress you know the
boys
run from there
because there's no job in the north so
when they are here
the things that they Bend small small
the copper and the rest they sell it to
make some small money because in the
North
it is like farming and if let's say it
is not raining you can't go to farm
[Music]
I feel like a winner in this life person
it hurts my heart makes me feel so bad
to see my little brothers and sisters
can get food for eat Mr Wicked Man down
to push this no feather oh you sleep at
night that's the superpower mama got a
skill we ain't got no dude Papa gonna
School
misleading the local youth with them
goons and drugs trying to move to sanity
reading materiality see the house
I don't know which place I'll go sleep
may I never know may I need to burn then
get money look my parents my fathers my
family
thank you
again
[Music]
as you can see the flag down there that
is where I used to sleep where we head
into where you can see Ghana flag
hanging that is where when I came I
usually sleep it was a place we used to
spread just spread a box around and then
you get something little to just cover
yourself then you sleep I stayed for
that for about um three to four months
um outside you know sleeping around this
water it was even deeper than this and I
think now because you know years has
taken place the place has been fold up
as you can even see example an example
of the water still lying down
so you can see there was a lot of water
here and we're staying just exactly
after that place you know you can see
how bad it was as I was then sleeping
outside you know the mosquitoes um
side that they said they smell people
used to die friends used to die and it
was something that was like running
through my mind my brain I was I was
very bad and I was like looking when
when would I live here and praying to
live
you know living here and breaking
computers breaking E-Waste materials
just to pick copper Pig metal you know
I'm now happy today I'm no more breaking
computers just to pick parts or pick us
but today I'm now using computer hey you
hey
hey boy
so you if you think you want to do
something have it in mind this is what I
want to do even if you're not qualified
you can still go back and write Bec
you can use that certificate to apply
for something we understand and you go
into an institution to ask their
qualifications and then their tuition
you definitely ask for forms maybe the
forms they say is 20 Ghana and I'm sure
maybe here you get money maybe in a week
you can get like 30 grand you can save
the little
maybe in a month you can go and acquire
the
the the this on the tuition don't wait
for help you can only like try climbing
then you ask for push
when you try climbing then people can
help push you you can start with nothing
but you must try to help yourself yeah
in your own way
honorary survival I'm gonna stay alive
too hard not to crack nowhere to run I
got no place to hide and
Zone
too hard not to crack nowhere to run I
can do it to ride it
I'm a real survival
as a foreigner you may look at us from
all the war comes into the country as
second hand Goods in form of electronics
or even very old cars or what's not my
brother it goes beyond that
go to the various abattoirs where we
Slaughter cows and goats we use ties I
mean car ties in burning those animals
and this is not a secret they don't hide
to do it you see them just look for
those old used ties put petrol on it
set it Ablaze and put the animals on it
for us to turn it just to burn away the
fur burn away the hair and this is what
we consume it is not only for the low
class no
the ministers also buy from the chopas
and that is how they they skin their
meats is goes to the restaurant it goes
everywhere that's a day-to-day
challenges of E-Waste we are seeing
[Music]
happier
cause to eat only
since
rashes because of mosquitoes
look the red ants they were eating my
legs and that is where they sleep
mosquitoes
mosquito bite you want medicine to treat
all our bodies
see all my this place always this place
mosquito bites
my body is aching
is
beautiful
all right
10 minutes
[Music]
banglades.com
so yeah
this last week Friday one of them was
going about the road picking the the
those wires and and use computer stuff
so when it was going around picking them
it was knocked down by by a car so he
didn't die on a spot but the lady who
knocked her who knocked him with the car
have to rush came to our teaching
Hospital which is callable teaching
hospital but when they got there there
the doctors over there didn't attend to
him and due to that he died he died on a
spot as we buried him we have to send
part of part of his uh we have like
something that we call Tradition so part
of the staff that they moved from the
fingernails and stuff we have to be able
to send him to the mother who is the
only family in the north the village
that he comes from is so we have to be
able to carry the remaining of the Body
for the family to also see and believe
because us when they see the remaining
they know that yes it is true the sun is
dead
yeah so because we don't have the money
to go through the the you know the the
necessary procedure where he was not
taken care of and he has to you have to
die
[Music]
what I found is it if I went back to uh
to Africa and I found one of my students
taking a laptop and repairing it by
replacing the capacitor generating 700
worth of value in 45 minutes of work
I would see the most exciting thing I
could imagine
and
right now the problem is that a hotel
like this one with uh more than a
thousand rooms they replace televisions
you know the big working CRT televisions
from hotels like this around the country
and around England
you know thousands of working TVs
because their customers want flat
somebody like Joe Benson in uh London
sees hey suddenly there's uh
600 working CRT televisions he takes
them and he sells them and
and if you go there you'll find those
are not the TVs being filmed with the
kids in the dumps the kids in the dumps
have some white monitor from 1995.
you know that's what's being burned but
what's happening is
people are reacting not to the color of
the black TV or the white monitor
they're reacting to the color of the
kids
and it's turned into
a bizarre racial profiling
of the best and brightest people in
Africa
and this year they actually put a guy in
jail for it
[Music]
our business is mainly for reuse by
ourselves we have a question for all
over Africa countries every customer
have the fire
they have their passport copy on the
they have the company name they have
their invoices first business 2008 when
they start coming around then I have
include this business they exists
when they start coming they're not happy
with the testing you and I have a clue
with television so if I remember I just
can't understand it telling you oh I
open this container our cable of TV is
caught to change the cable take you five
minutes two minutes to change cable I
can rewire the whole TV for about 10
minutes if you will not use what we have
we keep on breaking down we keep on
building what happened to the
environment environmental gift
but I just really be honest and be
truthful they should go to Africa first
African government to have recycle
everywhere
[Music]
people like Joe Benson and others to
engage in the same type of business or
actually doing something very sensible
because they're making sure that people
who cannot afford to buy new products as
he also said
can can still make use of this equipment
and the equipment's life will be
prolonged he as a businessman and
somebody using Common Sense uh would not
pay for something that is waste if
something is uh used and reused and
reused and reused and in the end in the
end there will be there will come a
point where it does become waste and
there he said you know in that when that
happens there's no recycling facilities
in Africa which is also very true the
traditional notion uh that you know the
legislation like the Basel convention is
based on
is
to put it in a simplified manner that
everything that's used is waste
and that is the reason for that is as I
said that at the time when the
convention was negotiated in the late
1980s you did not have a us there's a
problem it's not really clearly clearly
defined what is what is e-waste and what
isn't my my vision if that's not too
grandiose of a word is really to see a
world where
um wastes become resources
[Music]
thank you
like 1970s
whereby John Bessie is not the only
person who is shipping use Electronics
to Ghana so bro I'm I'm part of it I'm
one of them
simply because the reason why I say I'm
proud of it I'm one of them the
government charged me Duty
and I can pay like ten thousand dollars
or more
when it comes to duty
so I see that day to day it's gonna take
time for them to realize where we are
telling them to do is the right way it's
gonna take time but we can't just use
one day to force them to change what
they are already used to but to me my
opinion I believe them being a leaders
of that place if we let them know all
these things and we and let them know
that the effects of burning if we let
them know that it have harm to them in
the future I think they to their human
being they want to live for long five
years ago it went insane
uh Interpol created a thing called
project Eden to start to arrest all of
the people who are importing televisions
to Africa people like Joe Benson and
hundreds of others my my friend wahab
and that's where we said we've got to
get active we formed an association fair
trade recycling to try to create a
network in Africa's Tech sector so that
they can communicate better to The
Regulators that I used to work with and
say time out in the environmental
Community needs to wake up to the idea
of collateral damage that by raising
money in this way and telling ourselves
petting ourselves in the back that we're
the great white savior you know saving
these people when actually if you
arrested one thousand Joe Benson's if
you arrested every wahhab you would do
nothing to stop the flow of material
into agbag bloshi that was imported 20
years ago
foreign
[Music]
the most harmful thing is the burning of
the wire because of the dioxins and the
toxins that are created from when you
burn off all the plastic to get the
copper so I thought that was the best
thing to solve because it's the thing
that has the biggest impact on the
environment and the biggest impact on
the People's Health that are doing it
so the way the system works is that you
put wires in the top here and inside
there's a shredder that shreds it up so
there's a series of blades that spin
around and Shred up the wiring and then
it comes out the bottom here
and it comes out as lots of bits of
plastic and lots of bits of metal so
that is then a big mix of stuff that you
have to separate into which is the hard
bit so shredding up wire is quite easy
you don't need anything too technical to
do that but then to separate the plastic
from the metal you need to develop
another machine to do that which is this
machine over here should I bring it over
here or
foreign
works is that there's a pump that sits
under the bicycle wheel and it pumps
water into here and it comes out of
holes up here and it also causes this
this Basin to rotate what happens is
that all the material gets into the
water but because the copper is slightly
heavier it stays on this lip and is
carried up the Basin and through the
hole in the center but because the
plastic is slightly lighter it gets
washed away or out of the Basin and into
here so then you end up with all the
copper being collected in a small bucket
that sits behind the hole and then all
the plastic ends up in the basin
that's basically it
I'm happy with it as in a it's a system
that sort of that works but I'm not
happy in terms of the fact it hasn't
actually been deployed it's not
something that's been implemented at the
moment it remains a concept rather than
a solution
so the key is making sure that money
comes back down in the system to the
person who is cycling and therefore they
do it because they earn a lot more money
will fit up to 30 more money from the
cycling and so I think really they don't
need to you don't need to explain the
technicality or explain an environmental
reason for doing it it has to be that
you explain a financial reason for doing
it if you do this you can make more
money than you do at the moment and I
think that's how you can convince people
to to use a system like this
nothing
[Music]
good job
so you see that's what I'm needing to
buy a house this is my brother's house I
can get
foreign
[Music]
put your camera down pick trotrow a
local commercial bus you will see many
vehicles in Accra here
is should I blame the white man no who
takes income tax on that vehicle the
government of Ghana who gave that
vehicle Road wedding license the
government of Ghana who ensured that
vehicle the government of Ghana why
should I blame the white spot who stays
in this country and has not done
anything wrong so he says Lame Game you
keep Shifting the blame but you've not
solved the problem okay so let's say it
is not anybody's fault but I think
that's still here if we really want to
stop them why are we not fighting them
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]